اول مره ظهر على الشاشه كان طفل صغير وعمل
دورين صغار مع والده في فيلم قلب جريء
وبحبك وانا كمان وبعدها غب سنه وقت ورجعنا
يعني من كم سنه شفنا ممثل شاب موهبه لافته
بيطل بفاجئنا حتى في ادوار عده بنتكلم نحن
تحديدا عن ايام مصطفى قمر من ليالي
الحلميه الجزء السادس لابو البنات لخيانه
عهد لاهدى اللي صار اللي زي القمر الا انا
وغيرها كمان وحقيقه هو من بين الفنانين
الشباب اللي قدروا يثبت وجودهم على الساحه
وجماهيريه كمان يحجزوا نفسهم كمان اما كان
لهم في الوسط حتى الفني على مدار الكلسنه
اللي فاتوا شفنا تيام امر ممثل في الدراما
بشكل اساسي وكم تجربه سينمائيه لكن هو
اليوم بطل سينمائي كمان الصف الاخير فيلم
من بطولته ومعه بيومي فؤاد وبينافس مو بس
يدور السينما المصريه بالكمان دور السينما
العربيه وفي بيلعب تيام دور شاب قليل
الخبره بالحياه وبيشوف كل شيء حوله من
زاويه واحده وبخوض رحله من يوم واحد بتقلب
له كل المفاهيم
انا حاسس ان مشكلتك معايا انا مش مع
المسرحيه وانت بتتفرج على المسرحيه تقعد
في الصف الاخير مسرحيه بتحكي على امير
وتغويه غنيه دي بقى لا بوظف الكلمه يعني
واحده بتغني ولا بنت شمال
رشيد الدمنهوري ولا رشيد الاسيوطي افخم
على شكلك سرقت
والدتي طبعا من اكبر الداعمين له انتشرت
صور كثير لهم سوا في افتتاح الفيلم فيه
مصر ايام اليوم منورنا في تفاعلكم ولاول
مره عشان نتكلم عن الفيلم ومشواره لغايه
الان ومشاريعه المستقبليه كمان واللي فيه
من ضمنها مفاجاه حلوه ان كشف عنها من ايام
طيب ينضم الينا من القاهره الفنان تيام
مصطفى قمر اهلا فيك معانا منورنا وخلينا
اول شيء نحسم الجدل هو تيام ولا تيام وايش
معنى الاسم
ايش يعني تيام
تيام جايه من متيم
على وزن فعال
حلو طيب وعلى السيره انت متيم
يعني في بوادر
حلو طب احد مشهور
لا
بنهزر على فكره
لا لانه خلص بما انه دخلنا في موضوع الحب
وقلنا تيام ومتيم وكذا ما انت دايما في
اشاعات بتربطك بكثير من زميلاتك فخلينا
نخلص من ده الموضوع اشاعات ولا حقيقه
شعاعات كلها اشاعات مغرضه وكلنا اصحاب وما
فيش اي حاجه من الكلام ده طيب خلاص بما
انه هذا الكلام الاخير خلينا نتكلم عن
الفيلم الصف الاخير احكيلنا عن هذا الفيلم
تجربتك في اول بطوله يعني لك
هو انا كنت متحمس جدا ان انا اعمل الفيلم
ده انا من زمان وانا نفسي ادخل السينما
قوي ان انا بحب السينما جدا فانا يعني
تحملت اكتر لما لقيت ان انا هبقى مع النجم
طبعا كبير قوي ده يوم فؤاد يعني انا بحبه
جدا ومن جمهوره واشتغلنا مع بعض قبل كده
في خيانه عهد وفارس بلا جواز بس ما
اشتغلناش مع بعض
بالانتان سيتي دي
انا انبسطت جدا بالتجربه دي والقصه كمان
كانت مختلفه ولذيذه
والفيلم فيه برده وجهه نظر فنيه كده انا
حطيت ان انا يعني بعمل حاجه مختلفه
للسينما فانا كنت مبسوط جدا ان ده دخولين
ده حسيت انه مختلف لانه يعني بيدور انه
كذا في يوم واحد ولا حسيت انه مختلف كمان
لانه القصه هل حسيت فيها تشابه بينك بينك
وبين الشاب اللي بتقدمه
يعني انا مش قريب قوي للشخصيه بس انا حبيت
الشخصيه جدا ولكن اللي انا حسيته مختلف
قوي هو فكره
الرساله اللي الفيلم عايز يوصلها
والانسانيه اللي موجوده في الفيلم فانا
حبيت قوي ان ان يكون في في رساله انسانيه
متوجهه
للمشاهد زائد ان الفيلم كمان عباره عن
رحله فدي حاجه لطيفه قوي ان المشاهد بياخذ
الرحله دي مع الكارت فدي برده كانت حاجه
لطيفه واضافه للفيلم وانا كمان انا اتفرجت
على على الفيلم لاول مره في العرض الخاص
يعني انا كنت خالص ولا كنت بحبك اتفرج في
النص فانا لما اتفرجت بقى في العرض الخاص
يعني انا انبسطت قوي حسيت ان انا فعلا
طالع الرحله دي معاهم طب حلوه لما نتفرجت
علي بما انك انت ما تفرجت عليه يعني وهو
لسه بيتمنتج والكلام هذا كله تفاصيل هذه
لما شفته كده وانت جالس مع الجمهور كما
اعطيت نفسك من عشره
مش هقدر اقيم نفسي لا كده بس كده بينك
وبين نفسك قلت برافو يا تيام يعني يا ولد
يعني دايما اطلع الحاجات اللي هو اقول لا
الحته دي كانت ممكن تبقى احسن بس ممكن اخد
دي من طريقه مختلفه فعمري ما هكون مبسوط
ميه في الميه يعني
خليني اقول كمان يعني انا كثير من الناس
اللي بقابلهم يعني مثلا بتجيهم البطوله بس
بتجيهم دايما يعني او غالبا خلينا نقول
متاخره فدائما بنسالهم انه يعني بتحس انك
انظلمت بتحس انك انت تاخرت عليك البطوله
في حالتك انت العكس انت ما شاء الله يعني
العمر كله ان شاء الله وفي بدايه المشوار
وما الى ذلك وما شاء الله جاتك البطوله
على طول ما خفت ان البطوله جايه بدري
وانا اولا بعتبر نفسي محظوظ جدا
وباحمد ربنا كل يوم على كل فرص اللي
بتجيلي ويا رب اكون قد الفرص دي وبحاول
اهتم بكل حاجه بتجيلي وديها 110% من
مجهودي وتركيزي
ودائما حريص على ان كل حاجه بعملها هتكون
مختلفه وازهر الناس بشكل جديد فانا مش مش
مقتنع ان ان علشان انا في سن صغير جات لي
فرص كويسه او انا عملت بطوله معناها ان ان
انا تركلي كل حاجه بعد كده
البطوله والدوله مطلقه ولا لا بالعكس انا
انا عارف ان الدور هو اللي بيحكم القصه هي
اللي بتحكم فانا انا انا يعني ما عنديش اي
اعتراض ان الفيلم الجاي يبقى دور اصغر
بكتير او او حاجه اطلع بشكل مختلف يعني مش
علشان عملتها دلوقتي معناها ان هو كده
يعني خلينا كمان نكون واقعيين يعني في
السوق وفي الفن تحدي كلنا الواحد يطلع
خطوه لازم يحافظ على الخطوه اللي اخذها اي
شيء خطوه ثانيه مثلا حتى تعتبر تراجع في
مسيرتك الفنيه وممكن تنفهم غلط سواء من
الجمهور او من زملائك اللي حواليناك اكيد
طبعا بس انا بعتبر الخطوات مش مش معناها
بس حجم الدور هي معناه نوعيه الدور وظهورك
للجمهور ده بيبقى شكله عامل ازاي وانت
بتقدم نفسك كممثل بطريقه شكلها عامل ازاي
فانا موضوع حجم الدور ده بيبقى اخر حاجه
ببص عليها لكن انا بفكر انا الخطوه دي
هتضيف لي ايه في الكبير بتاعي او في
مسيرتي طيب بما انه يعني كنا بنتكلم عن
البطوله وانه كيف جاتك وبتعتبر نفسك محظوظ
وكذا كمان كثير ناس بيقولوا صح تيام محظوظ
لانه في نفس الوقت ابن مصطفى قمر وابن هذا
الوسط الفني وصراحه يعني في الفتره
الاخيره الموضوع ما عاد مصادفه صراحه ما
شاء الله الوسط الفني كله اولاده دخلوا
السوق صراحه ههه حقيقه يعني في البدايه
كان واحد اثنين الان لا خلاص كلكم دخلتوا
فكيف بتحس تجاهل الموضوع
والله يعني انا اول لما بدات امثل تاني
لما كبرت حسيت ان كان في
اولا سبوت لايت علي ان انا
دايما محطوط
[موسيقى]
العنوان بتاع ده ابنه مصطفى قمر فانا حسيت
ان هو طيب انا بحاول اثبت نفسي كممثل فانا
طالما جاءت لي فرصه كويسه واولا هو الفرص
برده اللي بتيجي ما بتبقاش علشان ده ابن
مصطفى قمر فهناخده يعني انا مش مقتنع خالص
ان في حاجه اسمها تمثيل بالوسط يعني
المخرج عمره ما هياخذني لو هو مش مقتنع
بيا لو هو شايف ان انا مش لايق على الدور
لو هو شايف ان انا هفشله مش هياخذني فهو
انا هتاخد في دور علشان انا اصلح للدور ده
او هو المخرج ليه وجهه نظر معين فانا
بحاول على قد ما اقدر ان انا اكون قد
الفرص دي وان انا دائما يعني
النجاحاتي
لمجهودي انا
وشطارتي
اللي انا بحطها في شغل فانا بحاول على قد
ما اقدر يعني انا كل حاجه عملتها كان يعني
المسلسلات اللي انت قلتيها كلها كانت بره
بابا بابا
خليني اسالك انه على الفيلم الصف الاخير
الان بتحس انه انظلم مصريا
اكثر من عربيه يعني عربيا حصل على مشاهده
اكبر
هو انا حاسس ان الفيلم ده من النوعيه اللي
هتوصل اكتر للجمهور على على منصه اكثر من
سينما مع انه
متشاف كويس اكثر بكثير قوي في الخليج وفي
الامارات فده برضو شيء يعني يسعدني جدا
فانا حاسس ان الفيلم ده ان شاء الله برضه
لما يوصل للناس بطريقه مختلفه الناس
هتشوفوا اكثر
وهيوصل لهم يعني ادفع طب سريعا احكيلنا عن
اللي هو اولاد حريم كريم
الناس تحمست على الموضوع
انا انا اصلا كنت متحمسك ده جدا قبل ما
اكون فيه فاول لما قالولي عايز تبقى معنا
في الفيلم انا تحمست واكثر ان انا وبابا
نفسنا من زمان قوي ان احنا الاتنين نعمل
مع بعض بسعدد علينا كتير بس احنا مستنيين
يكون حاجه تستاهل وحاجه قويه
تحمسنا احنا الاثنين جدا للفرشه دي وانا
شايف ان الفيلم ده ان شاء الله يعني هيبقى
احلى من الاولاني ان هو
في نفس الابطال بتوع قبل كده استاذه داليا
البحيري استاذه علاوي استاذه بسمه وفي
ابطال جديده
استاذه بشرى واستاذ عمرو عبد الجليل
والشباب بقى كلهم
ان شاء الله يعني
هتكون تجربه ان شاء الله كلنا متحمسين لها
تيام انا بشكرك جدا على ظهورك معنا اليوم
وحقيقه يعني طريقه حوارك واجوبتك وادائك
اكبر من عمرك بكثير يا تيام فان شاء الله
بالتوفيق دائما ومن نجاح لنجاح يا رب
[موسيقى]